If you want to lead
something, start by saying,
this is what I care about.
This is what I
want to do and why
I think you should care about
it and you should want to help.
Hardly a day goes
by that I don't
think how fast my
life has flown,
how I remember as if it were
yesterday the first day I
became president.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hardly anything worth
doing can be done alone.
This is a particularly
disorienting time for billions
of people in the world.
You've got major
uncertainties about what's
going to happen in
the years ahead.
At a time like that, you really
need good leadership skills.
And you need people
whose goal it
is to pull people together,
not drive them apart.
People need to
feel the potential
to create a better tomorrow.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
This class is unlike
anything I've ever done.
I'll be teaching skills
I developed and used
in very challenging
leadership positions.
And I hope that those
skills will help you
in your personal and
professional lives.
You'll learn how
to work with people
you don't agree with,
may not even like,
and how to mediate conflicts.
I don't believe being nice
is inconsistent with being
tough and smart.
You've got to be tough as
nails with your tender heart.
I have encountered
a lot of setbacks.
I lost two elections
after I entered politics.
I've had ferocious
opposition, where
the whole strategy was to try
to destroy me as a person.
My mother died after
I became president.
I've had a lot of
things that really hurt.
But in the end, the
great adventure of life
is what you decide
to do with it.
We're all struggling mortals
with fleeting lives who
are trying to be right
as often as we can
and trying to live a life
that amounts to something.
A good leader will
share the credit
when something good happens
and assume responsibility
for the mistakes and not
look for a scapegoat.
I believe leaders
are not just born.
They are also made.
And I hope everybody who watches
this will say, what am I going
to do to be a better leader?
I'm President Bill Clinton,
and this is MasterClass.
[MUSIC PLAYING]